most of this generation quits the second
they get talked to you did this wrong
you did this wrong it's so easy to be
great nowadays most people are weak this
is a softened generation so if you have
any mental toughness any ability if you
have any fraction of self-discipline the
ability to not want to do it but still
do it people have a hard thing to
understand I hate to run and what makes
me so crazy people go well why do you
run if you hate it what are you talking
about I don't want to take showers and
eat either I hate that too that's a life
man it wasn't until I changed that
mentality that I became somebody I hated
going to school so guess what I was Dumb
and one plus one is two but if you
can get through to doing things that you
hate to do on the other side is
greatness that's what people understand
by me running I am callous in my mind
I'm not training for a race I'm training
for life I'm training for the time when
I get that two o'clock in the morning
call that my mom is dead or something
happens tragic in life I don't fall
apart do it anyway is a mindset trick
that you can use when you start to feel
excuses rolling up it works a lot like
the five second rule you have said to
yourself okay I'm going to talk to my
boss today about that thing that I've
been avoiding talking to them about and
then the moment comes where you've got
to have that conversation or the moment
comes where it's time to pack up your
bag and leave your desk and go to the
gym and what always happens you don't
feel like it I bet there are plenty of
you watching that have made a commitment
that I'm not going to have a drink
tonight and then guess what happens when
you get home you don't feel like not
drinking you feel like having a drink
here's what do it anyway has done for me
the idea that I just do it anyway has
pushed me to realize and to recognize
that there are a lot of moments when
there are things in my life that I
really want to do I need to do but when
the moment comes I don't feel like it
and so I pull out this idea of you know
what I'm just gonna do it anyway it's
raining outside I said I would go for a
short run I don't feel like it I'm gonna
do it anyway it's six o'clock in the
morning I'm tired it's cold I laid out
my yoga clothes but now I don't feel
like it what do I do I do it anyway when
you start to say to yourself I'm gonna
do it anyway what happens is something
really cool you acknowledge that there
are feelings that you have that are
trying to swoop in and hijack you and
you basically say guess what I'm gonna
do it anyway
an addiction to distraction is the death
of your creative production and we all
know about the dopamine addiction that
happens when you play with your phone
and so every time we look for like every
time we play with a phone every time we
respond to a notification there's a shot
of dopamine that creates a habit and
then over time the Habit turns into an
addiction that is just as powerful as an
addiction to cocaine there's a concept
known as attention residue and every
single time you respond to a
notification every single time you look
at your phone you deliver or give a
piece of your Priceless attention to
that notification and if you do it a
hundred times a day then by the end of
the day you have zero Focus I was in a
high quality Hotel relatively recently
and I ordered a large bottle of Evian
water and I kid you not they delivered
11 bottles of Evian water you want to
talk about the mistakes being made it is
stunning there are very few people who
are fully present and yet one of the
traits of the great Geniuses is is this
they could spend law long stretches of
time in acute Focus thinking about one
project free of distraction and then in
the book I talked about the model it's
called transient hypofrontality which is
really Flow State we all can tap into
Flow State where genius lives but you
don't get to do there if you're checking
your phone all day long I think the best
way to prove your your value is to work
is to learn is to absorb to be a sponge
you always want to outwork your
potential you know as hard as you
believe you can work you can work harder
than that and that's what I tried to do
when I first came in a league but you
know basketball is such a direct
competition sport that me coming in at
17 I hated when like my teammates would
say you know I get hit with an elbow
right Shaq would hit me with elbow in
practice always had that extra chip on
my shoulder so like every day in
practice for me was really trying to
annihilate everybody that was that I was
playing against I wanted to prove you
don't need to babysit me and so it's
always that competitive nature the work
ethic and curiosity My Philosophy was a
very simple one you know Rudy was one of
my favorite films growing up after
watching that film I come to understand
if I could work that hard with my career
be and I made a promise to myself from
that day that I was going to work that
hard every single day so that when I do
retire I have no regrets and that was
the most important thing for me is to
leave no stone unturned get better every
single day and if I live that way then
over time you know I'd have something
that was beautiful that was my
philosophy it seems like a pretty simple
one but you know if you live your life
to just get better every single day and
do that for 20 years I mean what do you
have
also to make sure you're actually in
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there what do you think is the greatest
human skill not habit but mindset and
skill I think the ability to manage your
own mind and emotions is probably one of
the single most importance and maybe the
second is the ability to influence
others that's what makes you a leader
and hopefully you're doing that for a
higher good because there are all kinds
of leaders as you know I don't think
most people are very good at emotional
Fitness most people are just not as
happy as they could be and I did one
book money Master the game it's kind of
like this well only what I did in that
case is I interviewed 50 of the smartest
Financial people at work Ray dalio Carl
Icahn Warren Buffett and out of 50 of
them and I spent a lot of time with them
some have become really good friends
there's probably four or five that are
really happy people oh well money makes
people unhappy you know money has
nothing to do with money money makes you
more of what you are just magnifies if
you're mean you have more to be mean
with if you were kind you have more to
give you know but I think that most
people are just they haven't learned to
manage what's going inside doesn't
matter how much abundance they have
they're still unhappy we've all seen
people that great comedians that have
killed themselves and it's like they had
everything except they didn't Master
what's going on here and here you've got
to take responsibility for
energy that you
a video as much as humanly possible you
know we know so much more about the
brain than we did just 20 years ago
Neuroscience has taught us incredible
things like that our brains are
continuously shaped by our thoughts and
our experiences and you know this to be
true negativity is one of the most toxic
forces on the planet it's toxic for your
brain for your nervous system and for
your ability to stay motivated do me
this favor do not solicit or listen to
the opinions of people who are notorious
for just being Debbie downers the one
mistake that I've seen people make
consistently is they almost habitually
talk to the exact person who is the most
likely to shoot them down and make them
feel like right so don't do that and
here's another key I want you to always
consider the source meaning don't put a
lot of stock into other people's
opinions unless they're actually out
there consistently taking risks and
being brave and actually making things
happen I mean if you think about it
let's say you wanted to climb Mount
Everest would you ever take advice from
someone who's never even at tempted the
summit no of course not that would be
crazy so don't take advice from anyone
unless you really think it through most
people most Champions do not have
something that you do not have they lack
something that you have or a champion in
the Physical Realm a lot of times it's
they don't have an off switch they just
keep going and so to the same degree you
probably do things every single day that
you should not be doing and so what I
want to introduce to you is a concept of
the anti-routine as the most productive
routine that is humanly possible for you
to accomplish what you want number one
is obviously just shifting the
perspective of I need to do more things
and I need to add more things to my
routine when in fact you need to stop
doing things that you're currently doing
all that remains is the work to be done
priorities mean two things cannot be
equally important when you work on
something if I spend 30 minutes on both
things and I say this one's more
important than this one I can say that
but that's not reality because I
basically just said they were both
important which means neither of them
are which is why most people cannot get
done because is they cannot say no you
need to have a routine of saying no an
anti-routine and that is the thing
that's going to yield those outsized
Returns on productivity you can't do two
things with different levels of
importance it's either important or it's
not important so if you say this is the
priority then it means you do not do
other things besides that thing that is
how it is a priority that is how you
literally prioritize I often say that
there's only four things that are
holding you back as a human being one is
if your vision and goal is bigger than
your self-image so if you feel you
deserve it you can have this vision and
goal and be excited about and motivate
about it you will not do what it takes
to achieve too if you have limiting
beliefs your limiting beliefs will drive
your behavior three fear fear of being
embarrassed to shame ridicule to judge
if you're a failure fear of
disappointment and the fourth one by the
way is you're lacking the knowledge and
skill required so that actually sets up
a self-doubt trigger which activates the
Frankenstein brain which caused you to
lose motivation but most people prefer
to master
disappointment and comfort zones instead
of mastering change so if I master
disappointment I know what I got I just
have to deal with oh okay this is what I
got and if I master my comfort zone then
at least this is the devil I know versus
mastering change and we know what's
going on in our brain we know what's
happening neurologically biologically
emotionally physically and all of that
is a skill why not just Master change
why not become an adaptationist right
now in the time that you need it the
most in the world if you don't then
you're just going to keep repeating the
same patterns so Master change now and
make that one of your core competencies
and then you master your life you're
around people that say Hey money won't
make you happy I'm with you it ain't
gonna make you happy but it'll buy a
nice Villa
can bring your kids and some support and
some staff the last thing I'm going to
tell you is that money matters and you
got to get your money right don't waste
it don't lose it use it use it to make
yourself better if you have a business
use it to make yourself better and the
business better hire employees use it to
make yourself better the business better
to hire employees make them better and
then add more employees and then use it
to Market your company Market yourself
to reach new connections use money to go
out and meet the people that dream
bigger than you do and that have done
all these things I'm telling you which
is they're not wasting the weekends and
they're paying the price I promise you
you'll end up with a life it'll be
beyond anything you can dream or imagine
but I'm telling you AI is the
opportunity that you've been waiting for
but you have to make a move given how
much AI has already altered our systems
over the next few years I'm expecting it
to majorly accelerate our ability to
test and learn not just here in society
and whoever learns the fastest is going
to win this is all happening in plain
Insight everyone's talking about AI I
know this isn't the first time you're
hearing about it but to take advantage
of this moment I need you to do three
Simple Things One reframe your thinking
around AI don't see it as the enemy see
it as a tool it really is a phenomenal
tool you're not going to be replaced by
AI at least not yet you're going to be
replaced by a human using AI so please
be that human that's replacing other
people to do that you need to to figure
out how AI is going to disrupt you face
it head on don't run don't hide identify
your vulnerabilities and three identify
all of the AI tools that are relevant to
you and master them learn absolutely
everything you can if you even for a
second think it's a good idea for Apple
and Google and Facebook to help you be
less addicted you are on the path of
losing you don't like Instagram delete
it the second we allow ourselves to let
the machines help ourselves is the
second you become more vulnerable I
believe that you want Apple to limit the
amount of time you're on Instagram for
you like you think that's what you if
you want that Mazel Tov take it but like
I promise you then there's going to be
the next thing and the next thing and
the next thing social media is exposing
us it's not changing us there is no
social media brother they're empty pipes
social media doesn't make you mean
social media doesn't make you insecure
you're insecure you're me we're getting
exposed not changed we're addicted to
human interaction the reason the world
exists in a world where we've had atomic
bombs for 70 years is we like each other
when I'm addicted to social media we are
interactive creatures you're addicted to
people cool you don't want to be on
Instagram go read both knock yourself
out this is a very fun thing for me to
watch about people don't like being held
accountable
you are the product of the five people
that you spend the most time with you've
heard that before you know it's
important and the reason why it's so
true is because of a concept in
Persuasion in that whoever is more
confident wins whoever is more confident
in their opinion on something in their
habits on something is the one who wins
and persuades and influences other
people to join them even without having
to say anything just somebody being so
confident in their own negativity in
their own world and their own bad habits
without even telling you anything you
will naturally pick up on that thing and
dive down that same negative rabbit hole
with them and and that that's the fight
because if you are around people who are
negative who have the bad habits that
you don't want to have anymore it's not
that it's impossible but you're making
it a lot more challenged on yourself to
be able to pull yourself out of the hole
you are the result of the five people
that you spend the most time with so
let's say you want to work out you want
to work out you want to be healthy this
is the year you want to lose weight you
want to be in the best shape of your
life amazing right
but it's a new habit and this is the
problem at the very beginning of a new
habit if we go back to the concept of
persuasion
you don't have a lot of persuasion over
yourself yet you don't have a lot of
influence over yourself yet on this
habit because it's so new
so it's easy to get pulled in a million
different directions you're looking for
any possible reason why not to do it and
if you have a goal to go to the gym
every day or you have a goal to eat
healthy today
and then you see your friends around you
just diving in on Big Macs and lying on
the couch and complaining and being
negative
you can fight that
but at some point that fight starts to
wear down on you and your resolve isn't
strong enough yet because it's too new a
habit and so it's likely to happen is
you're gonna go join them because they
are more confident in their negative
approach than you are in the positive
approach they have such a history with
the bad habit
that didn't influence you to go back
down that negative path I remember
hanging out with a very popular YouTuber
and he was asking well how do I grow
even to the next step and I'm I love how
consistent you are he's talking about my
channel how consistent I was and when I
was
with him over dinner
one of the things that I struggled with
is when I travel I usually let my diet
go you know I'm traveling having fun I
don't have my usual routine and so not
that I would just smash Doritos down my
face but I would just eat whatever and
he was at a restaurant with me and he
was eating really clean he had a fish
and salad and no dressing and just
really really clean and was waking up
the next day he was gonna go for a run
some of those habits are what I do here
when I'm at home but I don't do it when
I travel and so here he was admiring how
consistent I was on making videos and
having however many thousands of videos
now on the channel and I was admiring
how consistent he was in his eating
healthy and his working out now what
would happen if we started to hang out
more
if we started to hang out more and we
look at those two things the consistency
on making videos and the staying healthy
on the consistency of making videos I am
so
it's just part of me now I'm so
confident in my making videos and that I
have to get it done that even if he was
lying on the couch all day not that he
would but even if he was he wouldn't
negatively influence me so I would suck
him to making more videos he would be
making more videos as a result of
hanging out with me it would just
naturally happen without me even saying
anything to him because here's what
would happen he might be on the couch he
might be getting distracted might be
doing something else I said okay man I
gotta go make videos and by me going off
and making videos it will motivate him
to go make more videos I don't have to
say anything your actions speak way
louder than your words don't tell
somebody to go do something you want to
influence and persuade them go do the
thing and they'll see you doing it now
it's in their environment and it's gonna
suck them in so if we hung up together
he would be more consistent on the
content
on the other hand if we hung out
together consistently
I would get healthier with my my travel
diet if I traveled every time with him
then we would likely eat at more healthy
restaurants he would likely be working
out every morning I would likely join
him on some of those he would just
hold me towards being a healthier
traveler compared to what I am now
because he is so confident in that habit
that he's trying to build and so where
we struggle as entrepreneurs is we're
trying to build these new habits we're
trying to pull ourselves up to a better
brighter future better place more proud
of ourselves but we're still stuck with
the people around us who are in a
negative environment who want to stay
stuck who just complain about where they
are instead of actually trying to build
something better for themselves so if
that remains your friend's Circle in the
next five years it's going to be really
really challenging for you to get to the
place where you want to be okay well
that's that's great Evan how do I change
it I mean I don't want to just leave my
friends I don't even know where to get
new friends how do I start this process
there are three big strategies I want to
give you that I think will really really
help first off you don't have to go off
and tell all your friends hey you guys
suck I'm better than you I don't want to
hang out with you anymore
right so step one is just do an audit
just do an audit of your friends just do
an audit of the five people that you
spend the most time with just think
about it in the past two months who have
you spent the most time with and then
how many of them make you feel better
about yourself where you leave them
feeling more bold more confident more
excited for your life more ready to go
and take on the big challenges that are
ahead of you and hand me them make you
feel worse how many of them you have to
go home and have a nap or how many of
them you just feel drained as a result
of talking to them not that they're bad
people they're just in a lot of pain
right again I don't think like there are
toxic people I just think that they're
in a lot of pain and and hurt people
hurt people right so if you're not
strong enough yet to influence them
they're gonna suck you down so step one
is to do an audit of your friends step
two is to limit access to the people who
are making you feel worse about yourself
again it doesn't mean you have to go and
tell them that they suck just just stop
spending time together
as you spend less time together you find
that the relationship just kind of
Fizzles away you don't have to have some
big conversation just kind of access
spend less time go out once a month
instead of once a week call them less
frequently stop doing things together
you'll just notice that as you spend
less time together
you stopped getting influenced so
negatively people are so afraid of
breaking off a friendship because they
think you have to have this really tough
conversation you don't
you don't you just have to spend
just look at your calendar see how often
you usually spend and your goal for next
month is to spend half the amount of
time or a quarter the amount of time
that you spent with them as last month
that's it that's step two it doesn't
have to be some big break doesn't have
to be crazy scary it doesn't have to be
overwhelming and massively painful it's
three is it going to be to fill the void
so if you stop spending time with people
two things happen one you get a this
void it's like well who do I spend time
with now I have this extra time in my
calendar I've got these blocks and the
other thing is you start to feel lonely
you know if you don't have that fun
circle around you anymore it's easy to
feel lonely which is maybe even worse
than spending time with them at least
you have some kind of connection we're
settling for just okay relationships
because we crave the connection because
you just want to have somebody around
you because it's better to be with that
person than it is to be alone
and that's the biggest fear is that
you're just gonna end up alone that
you'll never find anybody
even in romantic relationships but also
in your friendships because it can be
harder as you get older to join friends
circles to make new friends is why a lot
of people are still stuck with the same
friends they had in high school and
University because they never actually
went to go out and search for new
friends because it's so afraid that
you're gonna be stuck alone so in that
vacuum in that void in that hole in your
calendar now what are you gonna do well
the goal is to now meet new people and
you don't have to treat it like it's
dating it's a relationship you just go
off to the events and the and the people
that you
feel like you might have a connection to
so I'm introverted I'm shy I am not a
people person I hate networking events I
hate small talk
and so how I would do it if you're
extroverted it's super easy just go and
go to the events and hang out and say hi
and say hi I'm Evan good to meet you I
would never I never go up to anybody and
say hi I'm Evan it's great to meet you
what do you do I just I never do that
um so the easy way to do it is think
about the clubs the activities and the
events that are really interesting for
you that it's a lot more natural for you
to have a conversation about so if there
was just a business networking meeting I
would hate that I hate that kind of
stuff well you have to explain what it
is that you do and they don't really
care or interested in but finding common
Hobbies
so for me
I'll pick entrepreneurship I would pick
League of Legends I would pick salsa
dancing and signing into Minecraft so
maybe maybe some Minecraft I would pick
something in those four areas where I
could easily connect with people that it
doesn't feel like a chore to talk about
because I love that topic
as a quick example
um I was on an airplane and I was flying
to Brighton burchard's event in Puerto
Rico and so I was I was one of two
external speakers coming in to speak at
the event and this is his high level
Mastermind these are people who are
paying 30 to 50 000 to be in that room
and I'm flying down there and I you know
I'm in business class there's only one
person next to me and he's trying to
strike up a conversation and I I just I
just don't like it it's like so where
are you going like well we're going to
Puerto Rico like where are you coming
from I'm from Toronto and he was coming
up from Vancouver and I just I hate the
small talk right I hate the small talk
and so I think he kind of noticed after
a couple tries that I wasn't really
interested in talking to him I didn't
mean to be rude I just it doesn't
fulfill me I'd rather just be by myself
and alone and focus on what I need to
talk about and so we're flying down
there
and I don't really know why he's going
or what you know what he's going for
what his business is in Puerto Rico if
he's speaking if he's got an event what
so we don't really talk for the rest of
the way not anything rude just we're in
our own world
I get there and get in my uh my taxi or
Uber whatever and drive to the hotel
where we're staying
and as I'm checking in guess who shows
up right behind me
right next to me on the counter the same
guy that I spent all this time now just
sitting next to not talking to on the
airplane
and he said hey you're here too it's
like and as soon as I knew that he was
here for Brendan burchard's event it's
like yeah man are you here too oh my God
what's your business
as soon as I found out that he was an
entrepreneur it's it's way easier to
have a connection and so we spent a
little more time there chatting spent a
couple a couple of moments over the over
the course of the conference as well but
it's so much easier to make connections
when you have a joint interest right if
I know you're an entrepreneur or I know
you care about League of Legends or
Minecraft or salsa dancing if I know any
of those things we are instantly going
to be friends and have something to talk
about
but if you're just a normal human who
maybe I don't know anything about then
it's a lot more difficult so
because you have this vacuum and you
don't know who to connect with and you
want to feel that connection and
belonging with a group
don't let that hole and that pain drag
you back to the circle that you know
doesn't ultimately support you and look
for the events that are exciting for you
to go to for the clubs for the
activities that you are generally like
oh that'd be so cool to be able to go
there and you'll end up meeting
like-minded people and that becomes your
new friend Circle and when that happens
when you hold on to good people like
that you actually stop even caring that
some of the people
you know I've kind of drifted or you've
let go of at some point instead of
spending once a month with them now
maybe it's once a year just catching up
or maybe you don't talk again not again
because you've had some conversation and
they hate you you've just Grown Apart
and the last time you spend with
somebody the more you're gonna grow
apart you are the product of the five
people that you hang out with the most
you've heard it before you'll hear it
again when is the time to actually take
the action do the audit of your friend's
Circle do they make you feel better
about yourself or Worse about yourself
stop spend as much time with the people
that make you feel worse about yourself
and then feel the void fill the vacuum
with people who lift you up by going to
events and clubs and activities that you
genuinely care about it's not just a
strategy to make connections but you
love being there you will meet some
amazing like-minded people be
I want to celebrate you most
and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to learn
the habits of successful people to
accomplish your goals check the video
right there next to me I think you'll
love it continue to fully and I'll see
see you there I know you're a huge
reader but from a lifelong learning
perspective constantly trying to add to
your toolkit so that you're you know a
better leader a better CEO are there
recommendations that you have for the
audience